we're doing this right now because at
the end of interviews right we got how
to combine all these different kinds of
numbers in all kinds of different ways
right
now we know all our operations I'm
interested in how we can put them
together in the right combination yes
okay now when you have a look at this
simple simple mathematical expression
I'm a little bit puzzled because when I
look at this I'm not entirely sure what
this thing is equal to here's what I be
okay um huming what's three plus four
seven so if I say 3 plus 4 is 7 and then
I multiply that by 2 I get 7 times to be
14 very good but what I look at this if
I look at this stop remember try and go
through this as quickly as possible
allow me to do that if I look at it
another way and say well maybe I should
add the 3 of the 4 first
maybe I should multiply the 4 of the 2
first 4 times 2 of course is 8 excuse me
if you say 3 plus 8 you get which is
somewhat different to what I got in the
first place okay and this is kind of
this is kind of strange and a little bit
problematic for me because really I want
a language that means the same thing to
everyone no matter which way you look at
it right like that's the usefulness of
language to be able to communicate with
someone else okay if I say something
like a dog ok you want to all be
thinking of the same thing with full
legs and tail that wags you want to have
the same idea your hand along as we kind
of communicate so if I look at this one
stable and there are two ways to read it
that's a bit of a problem for me okay
the issue really is these things here
plus to the tires the operations right I
need to know what or I should do them
right which one should come first
that's why this idea is called cool yeah
okay this whole thing because it's about
the order which I do these plus minus
times divide America the heading is
order of operations now you will notice
I am very very deliberately avoiding
talking about any acronyms right now
there are a few avenues out there you
don't write this down but the most
common ones are but mass mass and our
friends in America call it PEMDAS now
don't write this down the reason why I
don't want you to write them down is
because acronyms right
they kind of Haiti to help you remember
things but they don't help you
understand things okay and I definitely
definitely do not want you to memorize
one of these these abbreviations that
say okay this is what it's all about I
just have to get this set of rules and
apply it wirelessly to this and they
don't get the right thoughts off at the
other end rules like that like violence
you going through rules like that is for
robots and you're human beings you're
mathematicians I want you to be thinking
about this business right so rather than
this I want you to have a little
subheading under this which is what do
the operations be what do the operations
mean now I'm just going to give you a
little bit of an idea under this we're
not going to go all the way bless you
because we don't even know what all of
the operations are yet we've got four of
them
but they're at war okay so I just will
give you a very very brief introduction
to this right and this will help us at
least answer this question for us okay
this particular one so what the
operations made let's think you had this
for an example okay you remember up here
I said seven times to seven times two
right what disability location actually
means seven times two it's actually an
abbreviation for something so right does
anyone know what it's a
oh okay
I got an abbreviation of 7+7 I would
point out then seven plus seven and
seven times two not much of an
abbreviation right it's like oh look
I've got three things three characters
or I've got three characters we'll be
along in the form of that that's still
equal to seven times two
what else could it review abbreviated
yes okay thank you I think we got the
right number right
I've written to seven times right in
fact that's why we use the word seven
times as synonymous with multiplication
because you're literally doing something
seven times
okay all those location is is an
abbreviation of addition in fact that's
so important we should all write it down
right because when you think about what
the operations me and one of them are
just shortcuts for the others so
multiplication is an abbreviation it's
an abbreviation on addition it's like
look if I want to do an addition a whole
bunch of times but I don't have to write
down a whole bunch of times
then I will just use this times sign
multiplication right it's kind of like a
shortcut because there's a keeps 18
mathematicians are famously lazy we want
to write as little as possible so I will
write rather than is I'll write this
it's quicker right therefore you can see
if multiplication is abbreviation of
addition right if you read something
like this is an abbreviation in that
sentence right what's the abbreviation
so in yes tradition
George which of course in abbreviation
for do not write so you really have to
think about the abbreviation first sorry
spared and you're mentally doing that
anyway before you think about the whole
sentence and exactly the same thing is
happening here okay which part of this
sentence this little phrase is the
abbreviation that's right
okay good there right here okay this
four times two is in fact short for 4
plus 4 right so 3 plus 4 times 2 I want
to look at the abbreviated pile to work
out what it really means which is 3 plus
and I could do this either way we've got
2 different ways you could write this
sum 4 times 2 right I could do 4 plus 4
or what would be another way that comes
from 4 times 2 just like we had it young
yeah very good ok
two fours and four twos okay and of
course here no matter which way you do
it if you really understand what
multiplication means you're gonna get
the same answer at the end 3 plus these
are both equal to 8 which gives us 11
this guy over here is Burgas okay so
what I'm trying to get across here is
remember when I showed you those
acronyms before those accurate is tell
you do multiplication before you do
addition right but it's not because
someone wrote down is now can scroll in
centuries ago oh we better do that
that's the rule it's because of what
multiplication is and what it means
question okay I'm so glad you asked now
bracket to the last really put a piece
that I'm gonna get under this operations
thing right suppose suppose I actually
did want to do the 3 and the 4 first
like maybe I want to double a group of
things over here another group of things
over here what credu this statement to
say do these first yeah brackets like
that they now be okay anything you see
in brackets you do that first now that I
put brackets in I put a bit blue you can
see this is what's gonna happen and it
would be 14 in this case okay so over
here what I'm doing is I'm using
brackets to indicate hey look
I tried through our attention to these
things it's a bit like highlighting with
their colors do this first this is the
most important thing and you can do that
to change the order if you want okay
which is why in pod mass now big is
first it stands for brackets right the
Americans who have P in the front that
word stands for parentheses which is
just another word I'll write it I'll
spell it for you so you know what it
means and parentheses in this context is
another word for brackets okay is there
a question yeah yeah sure okay so we'll
write this song you may like to now
write down now that you get this is not
about mindlessly following rules it's
about a way to remember what's going on
the B stands for brackets okay so
anytime you see these brackets now I
this is one reason why I don't like
letting it slow down now I actually
stands for index or indices which is not
something we've covered yet we will we
will I promise but it's like blue what's
that about
okay and you can't live in there okay
the DDM what do you think they stand for
because there's an operation that comes
first and opportunity comes second your
errands division and multiplication now
when you have a look at the acronym it
kind of seems to apply you do division
first and then multiplication but that's
not true multiplication and division
what do they mean they just kind of flip
sides of each other we looked at this
yesterday right let x 3 4 divided by 3
is just making something three times
bigger or baking a tree so smaller okay
so really these are what unit the DDM
which is why in the american version
which I told you is this they haven't
switched around
right so the MDD n that order doesn't
matter right there one thing together
and you can see just to end what do you
think these guys stand for
yeah ready add subtract and again it
could have been called being sawed
because you can do this attractants
press in the additions we generally just
gonna last
- right just like we normally read it's
not discern a has to be first do all be
adding first and Edna subtractions it's
not like